how can you organize your email I'm
gonna answer that question in today's
episode of luncheon urn so recent guy
asks a question from one of my loyal
YouTube viewers love you guys
mohamed saad who wrote in to say Evan
can you make a video on how to read tons
of email on Gmail and organize them I've
over fourteen thousand unread emails I
want to read them but it's mixed up I've
subscribed on too many email newsletters
that's why I have that much email so
we're gonna head over to my computer I'm
going to share how I use Gmail to
improve my productivity so the first
thing that's important is to use the
labels and the tabs so one of the things
that I find really helpful is this is my
primary inbox and this is where all of
the regular stuff comes to that I very
rarely check this will only be when I'm
standing in line at Whole Foods or you
know updating my driver's license you
know whatever I have extra time I got it
on my iPad and I'm answering questions
otherwise I use the labels down the side
so you know this is stuff to have to
look at for social these are videos I
have to respond to something for Nina
salsa related stuff are oDesk right I
have all these different labels that
have different meanings and they have
different times assigned to them the
other thing is at the top I use the tabs
and this tab is called forums although I
don't really use it for forms I've
deleted all my other tabs and this is
where all my priority email comes this
is the first inbox that I'll check on a
daily basis and it's from the people
that are on my team is from my big
customers it's from the media it's from
people who have a meaningful impact on
my business so if we look at it here
there's Ivan who's researching videos
for the YouTube channel there's
Alexander who was part of the salsa
business I'm attached to there's GT
who's with my website and it's Cristina
hey Kristina Kristina does all the video
editing and so I will check this before
I check anything else so use your tabs
wisely use your labels wisely and assign
specific times in your schedule in your
calendar to be able to attack those
things so that you can pull out the
priority ones the next thing I use our
Stars and I find that this is really
helpful to mark important emails that I
then need to follow up on so as an
example you know Kristina made a new
video for me normally what I would do is
review this quickly and give her a
message back but say this was an email
that I wanted to respond to later
more than a min one I would just click
on the star and I would archive it and
then if I go to my starred items here
you'll see that it's all other stuff
that I have to follow up on with people
and usually what I do is I sign a time
in my week one day per week to do my
admin day and that's when I'll follow up
on all of these things so you know when
I'm on my iPad doing my email and
there's something that I know I need to
get back to somebody on but it's not
urgent and I can wait to my pin day I'll
just hit the star archive it and then
when admin Day comes around I can pull
it up and answer those questions and
then the last thing this might be a
little bit of a harsh truth is maybe you
shouldn't be subscribing to so many
newsletters if you have over fourteen
thousand emails and you haven't read
through them maybe you should
unsubscribe from a chunk of those
newsletters and only take the ones out
that are meaningful to you that you can
actually act on because you can fill
your head with knowledge all day long
but if you don't take any action on it
you're never gonna grow your business
you're never gonna reach your goals
you're never gonna build that dream life
that you want for yourself and I had to
do this I found on my youtube
subscriptions I subscribed to a bunch of
channels and then I was missing videos
from the channels that I really loved
because all these other videos that I
subscribed to that we're just okay we're
filling up my stream and so I had to
segment them out and unsubscribe from a
bunch of channels so that I would make
sure that the ones that I really wanted
to read and watch were coming to my box
every day and so pick the five
newsletters that you loved the most and
unsubscribe from everything else so
those are some of my top Gmail tips I'd
love to know what yours are maybe I can
learn something too if you want to leave
it in the comments below thank you so
much for watching
need to believe and I'll see you soon